tomorrow is may the 4th may the 4th be
with you also known as star wars day
whether you're at home or gathered with
friends there are plenty of ways to have
fun exploring the galaxy lots of fans
love you can watch the book of boba fett
when it drops on disney plus maybe teach
your children about the galaxy far far
away by watching star wars kids and more
and for example couples that are no
longer flying solo can make it official
tomorrow and a may the 4th be with you
ceremony rocky is live at the little
vegas chapel getting a preview of how
you and yours can have a star wars
wedding to remember hey rocky
hey you guys yes so we have our lovely
cup look at them look at them already
dancing you guys are so excited come
through walk down the aisle you hear the
music
lovely lovely couple okay michael tell
us how we are how their ceremony is
going today walk us through the star
wars day wedding here at the little base
chapel all right so yeah we have our
couple standing up front and uh we have
a storm trooper who is presiding over
the ceremony here today
and uh in just a moment uh they will be
doing the sand ceremony and this sand is
very special because we acquired it uh
from the uh sands of tatooine wow
yes yes so it was really hard to acquire
and uh that was a long trip yeah it was
a very long trip it was actually light
years away
okay so you know after they do their
their ceremony what happens next what do
they get to do so after the ceremony uh
they will
they'll promise their love to one
another they'll exchange rings and then
they'll give each other a little smooch
and then after that they get to uh rule
the galaxy together wow okay they're
doing the same ceremony everybody look
at this hey let's get them doing the
sand ceremony that's beautiful
wow and i have a question our executive
producer is a huge star wars fan right
and she wants to know what if someone
wants to marry someone on the dark side
how do you guys
accommodate that
so to get to get married on the dark
side all we have to do is bring out
darth vader uh okay so we do have a
darth vader
officiant
you know if that's what you want yeah if
that's what you want we'll get the darth
to come in it's actually but uh yeah
we'll actually get uh princess leia
she'll be doing most of the ceremonies
tomorrow yeah oh you can't wait you
missed the kids you guys got to kiss
again there it is there it is all right
coming up we're going to talk packages
and what you guys can do here tomorrow
for star wars day i'll send it back to
you that looks like so much fun i love
it thanks